des dizaines de villes et de villages
inondés on n'est pas près d'oublier ce
dernier week-end de l'année dans tout le
quart nord-est de la france les pluies
et les crues ont fait de gros dégâts et
elles ont causé la mort d'un enfant de
cinq ans dans les vosges
victime d'une coulée de boue didier ben
régnant l'enfant dormait à l'étagé avec
sa petite soeur et sa grand mère toute
la journée il avait plu puis neigé
fragilisant un peu plus les toitures il
était 22h30 hier soir lorsque
soudainement une partie du toit s'est
effondré sous le poids d'une coulée de
boue j'ai regardé j'avais passé de
lumière en fait de l'ordre pourchassent
et puissante et j'ai pas entendu un
bruit comme on avait les enfants
devaient être inconscient pour moi je
suis monté les pompiers retrouveront
sous les décombres le corps sans vie du
garçonnet de 5 ans sa petite soeur et sa
grand mère légèrement blessés sont
hospitalisés
durement touché depuis deux jours par
des pluies torrentielles
ces alsaciens ont passé leur journée à
vider leurs caves et leurs logements
inondés à dimanche souvent synonymes de
galère pour tous les habitants de l'est
de la france
cet hôtel restaurant n'a pas échappé à
l'inondation
si sa cuisine est voilé mais si on sait
pas non plus chez cima hiver on l'a fait
c'est une cuisine qu'on a mis aux normes
l'année dernière vivez nature faire et
puis voilà aujourd'hui une lente décrue
s'est amorcée dans l'est de la france
mais il a tellement plu pendant ces
dernières 48 heures que de nombreuses
routes restent coupées à la circulation
une bonne nouvelle tout de même pour les
usagers de la sncf la circulation des
trains a été rétablie sur la ligne
toulouse dijon
le trafic avait dû être coupée hier
après-midi les rails étant inondée sur
plusieurs kilomètres aujourd'hui le beau
temps est revenu sur l'ensemble de la
région
mais avec un froid toujours aussi vif
les chaussées sont verglacées
prudence donc si vous devez vous
déplacer